this is the future of genetic testing
we've created a factory essentially a
genomics factory that can process
thousands of samples a day without human
intervention yeah it's the kind of thing
that makes you worried about your job
security but these robots are actually
here to lend a hand
welcome to Council in South San
Francisco home to one of the world's
first automated DNA testing labs
definitely a beautiful symphony of chaos
Kyle Lapham customizes the robots at the
heart of the operation he says that
automation is the best way to meet the
growing demand for genetic testing so
we've designed systems to very
accurately and precisely move tiny bits
of fluid from place to place our robots
perform these experiments with insanely
high precision it's also you can get
your genes tested at a more reasonable
price the more we know about our bodies
the more we can customize the treatment
in some cases we're looking for genes
that parents could pass on to their
children in other cases it's knowing
your risk factors for getting cancer so
each one of these tubes is a patient
they all now need to be sorted the
system is running 24 hours a day and not
waiting for people in order to perform
the next task you're gonna get a faster
turnaround time but these machines are
only as smart as their software you
could actually create paths in space and
teach the robot about the places that
can and can't go which means they'll
still have to answer to their human
overlords for now at least these robots
are essentially they're dumb they're
also potentially dangerous the
industrial robots that we use are
powerful enough to crush metal if
someone were to be in the space it would
just keep moving right through you but
we have a tremendous system of safety
features surrounding them that
essentially cut the power so if I were
to so much just stick my finger through
there you hear you hear a beep this this
arm just went dead so they've figured
out how to keep employees physically
safe but what about their livelihoods
we've continuously hired Clinical
Laboratory scientists by having robotics
it allows our scientists to focus on
what they're trained on which is
examining complicated genetic
instead of performing menial tasks just
don't expect these co-workers to take
you out for happy hour anytime soon